social media is not evil it's not good
or bad the problem is balance the
problem is how we use the tool and it's
like alcohol is fun too much alcohol is
actually very bad and I don't mean on a
nightly basis I mean on a regular basis
you know gambling totally fun but if
you're gambling your kids college
education fund away we have a problem
right so these things aren't inherently
good or bad it's a question of balance
and social media is the exact same thing
social many of course is wonderful we
connect with friends we can stay in
touch we can you know all of the share
of vacations pictures of our food you
know but the problem is balance which is
if we if we if it if it is an unbalanced
presence in our lives it will have
detrimental impact to the quality of our
friendships and our relate and our
ability to form deep meaningful
relationships it'll actually hurt our
ability to manage and deal with stress
because we find ourselves turning to
social media for validation or or or to
help us relax rather than turning to
human beings so I think the the big
problem is is that social media is
addictive it releases a chemical in our
body called dopamine which is the
chemical that's released when we gamble
when we drink when when we smoke that
makes us feel good and it makes us
excited and it's fun like when your
phone goes ding because the text came in
too you know like we all say we wish we
had less but if you really got zero
texts or zero dings in a day you would
some you would worry you know and the
problem is that it is it is a highly
highly highly highly highly addictive
chemical inside our bodies and so we
never we haven't we as a society have
not yet labeled social media or cell
phone addiction as a legitimate
addiction so we have no treatments for
it and just as we wouldn't give our
children access to alcohol or gambling
because their little brains are too
young to deal with the addictive
qualities of dopamine we have no
restrictions on the access we give our
children to equally addictive devices
and this is true for parents as it is
for companies by the way there should
not be a there needs to be there
shouldn't be no young children with any
actor young young children should have
zero access to the devices and older
children need to have more controls and
companies should ban cell phones and
conference rooms frankly there should be
no cell phones and conference rooms I've
inspired other organizations to try it
and I've checked in and asked them what
how it went and they said the quality of
did he said the meetings got shorter
ironically the beings got shorter the
quality of the relationships of their
teams improved communication generally
improved across the whole firm and with
clients they will literally take clients
phones away they'll have a basket and
say we all put our phones in this basket
you know no not even with your your
phone facedown it's not polite you know
it and they found that the relationships
with their clients have got better
simply because they have zero cell
phones on lunch tables office tables and
never in a conference room so I think I
think there's opportunity in in our
personal lives in our professional lives
[Music]